you probably don't need to be told how
important your brain is after all every
single thing you experience your
thoughts and your actions your
perceptions and your memories are
processed here in your body's control
center but if this already seems like a
lot for a single organ to handle it's
actually only a small part of what the
brain does most of its activities are
ones you'd never be aware of unless they
suddenly stopped the brain is made up of
billions of neurons and trillions of
connections neurons can be activated by
specific stimuli or thoughts but they
are also often spontaneously active some
fire cyclically
in a set pattern others fire rapidly in
short bursts before switching off or
remain quiet for long periods until
thousands of inputs from other neurons
line up in just the right way on a large
scale this results in elaborate rhythms
of internally generated brain activity
humming quietly in the background
whether we're awake asleep or trying not
to think about anything at all and these
spontaneously occurring brain functions
form the foundation upon which all other
brain functions rely the most crucial of
these automatically occurring activities
are the ones that keep us alive
for example while you've been paying
attention to this video spontaneous
activity in your brain has been
maintaining your breathing at 12 to 16
breaths a minute making sure that you
don't suffocate without any conscious
effort signals from parts of your
brainstem are sent through the spinal
cord to the muscles that inflate your
lungs making them expand and contract
whether or not you're paying attention
the neuronal circuits underlying such
rhythmic spontaneous activity are called
central pattern generators and control
many simple repetitive behaviors like
breathing walking and swallowing ongoing
neural activity also underlies our
sensory perception it may seem that the
neurons in your retina that translate
light into neural signals would remain
quiet in the dark but in fact the
retinal ganglion cells that communicate
with the brain are
always active and the signals they send
are increases and decreases in the rate
of activity rather than separate bursts
so at every level our nervous system is
teeming with spontaneous activity that
helps it interpret and respond to any
signals it might receive and our brains
autopilot isn't just limited to our
basic biological functions have you ever
been on the way home started thinking
about what's for dinner and then
realized you don't remember walking for
the past five minutes well we don't
understand all the details we do know
that the ongoing activity in multiple
parts of your brain is somehow able to
coordinate what is actually a complex
task involving both cognitive and motor
functions guiding you down the right
path and moving your legs while you're
getting dinner figured out but perhaps
the most interesting thing about
spontaneous brain function is its
involvement in one of the most
mysterious and poorly understood
phenomena of our body's sleep you may
shut down and become inactive at night
but your brain doesn't while you sleep
ongoing spontaneous activity gradually
becomes more and more synchronized
eventually developing into large
rhythmic neural oscillations that
envelop your brain this transition to
the more organized rhythms of sleep
starts with small clusters of neurons
tucked in the hypothalamus despite their
small number these neurons have a huge
effect in turning off brainstem regions
that normally keep you awake and alert
letting other parts like the cortex and
thalamus slowly slip into their own
default rhythms the deeper we fall into
sleep the slower and more synchronized
this rhythm becomes with the deepest
stages dominated by large amplitude low
frequency Delta waves but surprisingly
in the middle of this slow wave sleep
the brains synchronized spontaneous
activity repeatedly transitions into the
sort of varied bursts that occur when
we're wide awake this is the sleep stage
known as REM sleep where our eyes move
rapidly back and forth as we dream
neuro scientists are still trying to
answer many fundamental questions about
sleep such as its role in rejuvenating
cognitive capacity cellular homeostasis
and strengthening memory and more
broadly they are exploring how it is
that the brain can accomplish such
important and complex tasks such as
driving or even breathing without our
awareness but for now until we are
better able to understand the inner
workings of their spontaneous
functioning we need to give our brains
credit for being a much smarter than we
ourselves are